okay let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome
to the look back
at y'all
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up y'all
welcome to this special bonus youtube
only episode of griffin with griffin
uh shout out to my boy marshall on
instagram who put together a 30 minutes
of
just looking back at all the episodes or
you know
some of the episodes
of the last 199 episodes
because i'm gonna be doing a big 200
episode next week so this is just a
bonus youtube only i really appreciate
all your guys's support as always you
know
[Music]
and uh it's just been an honor and
pleasure
to be here doing this for you so make
sure you're working with griffin
make sure you subscribe
you know
uh
check me out on patreon if you want to
be a part of that
and obviously i'm on twitch
as always i'm on twitch so
this is it right now this is just a
quick 30 minute episodes it's a look
back a lot of my favorite episodes and
best moments of the show
[Music]
so i just want to thank you as always
for being here and uh here it is
[Music]
you know that little um hand let rest
the let the arm rust
she taps it
no she goes like this she went like this
she went
yeah like that's right yeah i went like
this
oh yeah like that to him
right to him right
right
no no
you don't know
it was building yeah why do you turn
into a wwf wrestler yeah every time you
yeah yeah you
yeah right and i just started like what
did you have to do you knew i know
no i liked it the lady echo you don't
know
boy but
so anyway my brain thoughts so now i'm
watching the movie and i'm sweating now
and now my brother is purposely laughing
oh he's okay he's going
i don't remember doing yeah
okay and then my brother does this this
is a great one uh-huh my brother
laughs and then he looks at her and he
goes
on the [ __ ] thing
hey an eye for an eye a two-for-two yeah
but she didn't do anything eye for an
eye this was biblical for her too
yeah okay all i did was i did the same
thing that she did to me i went yeah
and here now and that's all i did yeah
no that's no i didn't touch her
that's not all you did and then you
emotionally i'm steve yeah this is the
lady right this is what he does uh-huh
he goes
no no i didn't do that steve no i went
like this i went no
you did one i did two arms and i'm i'm
basically creating space
no no no no i'm doing this okay i was
there i know i'm doing both but you said
with one elbow i'm like okay well here's
the thing here's the thing
at that moment right now
there was already tension
so any move like that would come across
as aggressive so right so then what did
she do at that point so that her husband
oh jesus is now looking
like excuse me
yeah what
right i grab him by the hair no no no i
look at the husband yeah yeah cause yeah
okay cause now you're ready to go yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm ready i'm not gonna
i'm getting in my way wrestling i'm like
i'm thinking of like i'm ready i'm ready
i'm ready to shoot a movie yeah so he
looks a little bit and i'm like we're in
the middle we're in the middle of this
movie theater
san diego magazine san diego fireman's
carry yeah he was ready to go so i go
we're leaving i grab his hair yeah and i
drag him through like over
people right i drag them right
we go outside right right
and i have my ticket uh-huh i go thanks
for the present
happy birthday what was the worst
birthday what if you would have came out
and all your friends were in the lobby
surprise
oh that was all just like
that and the woman comes out oh yeah
god that would have been miriam
everybody
that would have been that would have
been amazing that would be that would
have been historical that's not what
happened
um people knew george collin as the
hippie dippy weather man right he did
the hippy dippy weather man for a lot of
years
and a lot of years and then finally
carlin went on a late night show might
have been the tonight show his amazing
clip if you can find it on on youtube
and he's standing there with a cardboard
cutout of himself as the hippie to be
weatherman but now he's like looking
more like carlin
and he comes on he's a leading jump in
george crowley brings the cardboard cut
out and he starts off and he's like he
goes um a lot of you know him this guy
made a lot of people laugh i know him
you know him too and then he took the
cardboard cutout and he dropped it
and he goes
but i'm not doing that guy anymore and i
hope that you'll come with me on this
new ride
let's start
and he reinvented himself almost
instantaneously by killing
the hippie-deputy weatherman so you feel
like the
the college bro
the bro
the you know itchy butthole dane cook
time to grow up got he's gone yeah and
that was the first time you were like
yeah when i ceased to be a child i put
away uh childish things you know it was
time to
really embrace that i'm an adult man
i've got you know good things that have
happened sure i can share stories that
you
that you'll say wow i mean that's
something that is so rare to experience
and i can make that funny but i can also
talk about the dark corners of life you
know what i mean i made it through
i made it through all that stuff man my
trials by fire all happened at once
it was just a bonfire
you were in a bonfire and they were
hitting you with emotions here's how i
knew it was intense i i finally got a
therapist four and a half years later
and after my first hour
he didn't say a word and then when i
finally finished he went like this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he had to go to therapy
[Laughter]
it was it was intense man just you also
have a picture of you
holding a giant fish yeah is that a
salmon
dude i did a movie and they made that
they made that that's not even real
but it looks good but it looks so real
that i was like oh look at me god i
could i could come up with a story just
lie to people and be like posed i was
like i don't think eric's a deep-sea
fisherman i'm not eating i like how now
you you there was a level of respect
that you started to that rose in you for
a second like this guy i didn't know
this guy i should have lied to you to be
like yeah that was a
75 pounder
off the coast to like some weird place
75 pounds i was like eric's holding that
thing up really nicely
and looking all casual off in the
distance with his client you didn't
wrote that thing with your glasses on i
think would you stop examining my sorry
man sorry i'm just picking apartment
how dare you but the one time i did try
to dunk in a game was like we were under
the basket and it was like the scramble
the balls and i just grabbed the ball
and i i just didn't know why drop step
try i i just and i tried to dunk the
ball i got fouled and the ball went
flying out everywhere and i people still
go nuts in high school for that though
right listen especially because
everybody was like i was the dorky sort
of kid that was just like you're tall
you come on eric you know and then it
was like
you know you know what happened i wish i
had i have footage of this i got to find
it but it's like actually i didn't get
fouled the ball just flew in the air and
i literally stopped playing because i
stopped i was in the middle of the game
and i was holding my shorts and i was
like i just tried to dump the ball in a
game but the game's going on and then my
friend got filed but everybody was going
crazy for me they were like oh my god
you know what i mean it's better than
the two points it was better than the
two points but because but i was really
like in my senior year i was coming into
myself like sort of confidence and
things like that because people were
hard on me you know like they were
really hard on me like i'll never forget
this it was like you know the dads were
hard on me like everybody i didn't know
my dad and my mom didn't even come to
the games because she was like i i
should have invited her it's not that
she didn't want to come it was just like
whatever because she worked you know i
was the only child she was single parent
but these dads would be like come on
eric come over eric you know they're
just like [ __ ] you know what i mean so
then
the one of my great moments was like i'm
in the post all the dads are sitting
right there and then like the guy's on
the outside he's got the ball he's
looking and then i posted the guy up and
this is what i said give me the ball on
this fool
and then i looked out i looked that's
almost racist dude i looked out and all
the dads were like that's right
oh that's so good and they were like
give him the ball and i got the ball you
know what i mean i just was like i never
forget what was like when you got the
ball i was like
and then i did like this
then i was like
travel [ __ ]
before you even shot it
you guys are so [ __ ]
insane with your [ __ ] man this is that
podcast brotherhood of nonsense i just
i'm just not in that yeah i'm actually
not in the crew you know i'm really
feeling like come on that's not true no
i'm not in the crew i feel like you were
in there you're in there with them i'm
in the outskirts i'm i'm
i'm in like if it was an onion i'm not
in the inner layer i'm not you know
segura you know and even andrew
santino's in there now you know andrew
and uh you know all these people they're
right there you know rogan's in the
center he's the center of the podcast
universe for this comp the west coast
comedy you know what i mean he's there
and i'm just not there you're good
you're fine what episode is this um this
will be like 42 or 40. just fine i'm not
saying exactly i'm on through like 370
right no but you guys do like do you
have that kind of stuff you guys are
gaining weight together oh come on
you're doing the same thing over here on
your own all by yourself
i walked right into that well you
haven't walked enough into it
eating a donut i want to thank tony for
coming on
i just kicked you out you've got that
good fat boy fat guy voice
i'm reuben stuttered over here
oh my god what is up with your wooz
you grew up in a black neighborhood and
that's your woo-woos whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
oh my god i actually had that was one of
my neighbors woo-woo jenkins
i'm telling you it was a real black
neighborhood
get back in the house i want to see the
woo life story he's got his own life
story well this is all we're trying to
establish right now i guess this is what
the people want to see because they love
this yeah but stay like this right
there's gonna be 50 000 views by the way
steve guaranteed all i'm trying to
establish is that luke skywalker
wasn't any more trained all right than
anybody that was a that was a jedi i'm
not gonna argue with you i'm not gonna
agree or disagree i'm just gonna leave
it at that because if we keep doing this
no no no no because i love luke all
right i love luke tell me when he
learned how to be a he'll tell you a
specific time but i we don't know where
ray learned all her [ __ ] either and
we'll just leave it at that we we don't
know we did we don't know the movie
opens up with this new jedi healing
power that we don't know no you're
talking about this is what i'm saying
you're jumping around we don't know let
me just can i finish my point yeah yeah
my finishing point the first movie opens
up with rey
beating up uh the black dude and beating
up two people that were trying to kidnap
her so all i'm saying is yeah she was a
skilled fighter and they established
that in the movie oh and she's like
ronda rousey of star wars you know she's
just a badass she could fight
well if you're if you're if you're a
girl living on a desert planet by
yourself you have to pick up some tips
and tricks to take care of yourself fair
enough fair enough okay and i want to
get off ray and luke right i want to say
i want to get to other bullet points
i know but all i'm saying is they showed
her using the stick and all i'm saying
is if you look at luke's god every time
you say stick
when you say this won't be just these
chopsticks man i don't care if she has
sticks it's not a lightsaber man okay
and my point is
when did luke become a master with a
lifesaver i told you i can't give you a
finite answer of what so then why is it
okay for him i don't know when ray
learned her [ __ ] either why is it okay
for luke and not okay for rey isn't the
question but but the only difference is
who beat the emperor luke didn't
rated you know ray's the most badass i
mean she well that's a whole different
art i know i
god we talked 20 minutes no at this
point we've already they showed that she
was trained at that point they showed
the train you know what i'm just going
to agree with you didn't they show the
training you're right eric you're right
she's the she's the best i didn't say
that's always the best you said that she
was more skilled than luke skywalker
ever was she was more small than obi-wan
kenobi nope nobody said more skilled
than darth vader nobody said there's
more escapes nobody said that anakin
nobody said that ben kenobi nobody said
that but you're i thought that was what
you're nobody said that i thought that's
what you're implying yeah you know what
you do when you assume things you make
an ass of yourself all right nobody said
that then then i'll just nobody
apologize to
nobody said that okay i'll say it for
the 17th time all right nobody's going
to just edit the last 30 minutes no this
is great this is not good because i'm i
don't know i was starting to sweat i
always sweat when i come here
oh my god
like somebody will dm me and they'll get
mad and they'll be like hey fat boy or
you know they just say they just use fat
but doesn't that go away for you that
see that to me feels like that's just
not even i know but it's like to me i
just go it's lazy it's if that's what i
don't like about it i'm like really yeah
as if as if i'm gonna be like this
what
[Laughter]
i'm fat
bro i've been living a skinny life for
so long now it's like you get some
[ __ ] you know and then like bobby
doesn't help with like you know well
yeah
he so we always joke about star wars
yeah so i always i always said he you
know he looked like yoda and he calls me
fat lando so it's like lando calrissian
was uh you know billy d williams
character i know he was well i know you
see it in like star wars i'm well added
i'm well adjusted as an adult i know
cultural zeitgeist i understand oh
excuse me that's see by the way that's
why i don't watch that [ __ ] i'm smart
enough to culturally get it so i'm okay
like look like do i know um um do i know
who um
[Music]
uh uh all the star wars characters are
yeah star trek i can't name you [ __ ] i
know who harry potter know who hermione
i know the cast well you have to know
ron weasley oh that's you that's another
another guy another garbage ass
character
ron was not a garbage character he was
not he was he was a hero he was harry's
side [ __ ] well he's
he can't be the main chick he's redhead
it's not gonna be the main chick
now i'm gonna start calling you fat in
this [ __ ]
i mean like i remember we would go to
yankee stadium or when my father would
come pick me up for the weekends like my
mother was like no soda no soda he's not
allowed to have soda and as soon as we
return the corner you know he'd give me
mountain dew right right like the worst
[ __ ] cause he's like you know whatever
he was the worst
yeah he was the worst but simultaneously
the best you know and so my father was
always the same thing like he would take
me to the racetrack but we weren't you
know being around his gambling friends
he was like oh we're gonna you know tell
your mother we went to the zoo you know
like things like that or when we go to
yankee games so what you're saying is
your father basically was undermining
everything your mother did everything
and you got a chick
i got a chick pregnant yeah i get it
okay every time i i'll never forget i
grew where i grew up in ridgewood on by
seneca avenue that's where my house was
every time we would get to the corner of
my where my block is in seneca avenue he
would walk me there and then walk across
the street into my mother's house he
would always say what what and you know
whatever we would do he would be like
remember don't tell your mother okay so
there was so many times like we're not
going to tell your mother about this so
i never ratted my dad out i just when
she got pregnant i was thinking so like
i kind of like needed my mom because i
was so nervous right about everything i
was like and then uh she hung up the
phone on me and didn't talk to me for
two weeks but then she came around and
has been the best grandma yeah well
because she the thing about it is i get
it because she made it work like she
probably
thought to herself okay i'm mad i'm mad
and now she was like okay i went through
this let me help my kid yeah you know go
through what i went through and then
maybe you're gonna break the cycle it
was funny too because my kid's mom is
beautiful donnie knows her beautiful
beautiful girl she's very latina puerto
rican girl from brooklyn my mother's
like an articulate white ivy league
woman so i bring home my baby mama and
rosie perez yeah she has a tattoo in her
tit your hair pulled back and my mother
just goes sometimes when you win yeah
she's like i want a fanta fanta and my
mother i'll never forget i'm like mom
this is my girl and my mother just took
a deep breath and she goes
she was like welcome to the family
she said and then she took a glass she
loves she blew her racism out yeah
she took a sip of pinot grigio and she
was like let's go in the living room
she tried to blow it out you know i saw
the i saw this movie on a plane and i
just watched it the other day with my
girl that uh isn't it romantic
yeah uh
and i was like this is such a sweet
movie but i gotta ask you though at the
end of the movie there's this big dance
sequence
and
it looked like a horrific day of
shooting
it actually wasn't that bad if you you
probably didn't notice i only noticed
because
it's me it's my face and my body so you
end up just kind of
you know how it is when you watch
yourself on a screen you like aren't
watching objectively you're just like
staring at your dumb face going like i
wish i wouldn't have
god i wish i would have ate those like
eight pieces of pizza the night before
my head looks atrocious
but i was we shot that that was like a
pickup
after the fact like the whole movie was
done in the can
edited and then they did some testing
and they were like
yeah we want like a big fun like what
was testing the highest was the song and
dance number in the bar
with the karaoke scene right right right
right and uh
and then they were like
yeah we want more of that especially
from like me and rebel like doing the
pitch perfect movies together they
wanted us singing and dancing more so
they like designed this whole song and
dance number but i was shooting the
righteous gemstones at the same at the
same time
so i had already got my big dumb
righteous gemstones haircut where like i
have my hair and like
the point
and they're like you can't cut it we're
like in between scenes like i flew to
new york from south carolina for like
four days to shoot that and then flew
back to continue with righteous
gemstones so they're like you can't cut
your hair so i have this big dumb hair
that kept like flopping around
while shooting that dance sequence and
the whole time i'm like it's not going
to cut together uh the whole movie's
ruined and meanwhile everyone's like no
one gives a [ __ ] about your hair adam
they're looking at priyanka chopra
they're laughing at rubble you're just
in the movie be happy
be happy you're just in the movie it was
actually a sweet movie yeah you're right
you you know you do that great like
everything every movie i've seen you in
where like you're just like because for
some reason you're always
that guy who wins in the end but he
wasn't winning the whole movie and then
finally people realize you know what
that guy is actually handsome you know
what it it's almost offensive by like
how long pigeonholed is like yeah
i'm definitely like the ugly friend who
[Music]
just that you settle for you go you know
what yeah
he's all right yeah you know what he is
a good guy yeah so what he's not
handsome like a hemsworth
well i mean it's hard having hemsworth
there like that [ __ ] is so
handsome for no reason at all it's just
he's disgustingly handsome so i get it
when you're next to him you're like okay
he's the leading man but like yeah he
really is a [ __ ] stub too he's so and
he's so goddamn talented it's kind of
off-putting
yeah you're like
jesus man yeah cause he he's so funny
and he's funny in that movie too and
he's like
yeah he's just a [ __ ] stud and you're
like yeah hey i get it
i get why uh hollywood is pigeonholed me
in this role and your pigeon holed as uh
i know as the super leading man
i get that have you ever not even tried
tried but like unintentionally
you're holding it normally and you can
smell the mic oh and you're like
[ __ ] it's just like
a hundred dudes with bad breath have
been hovering over it and you're like
you're holding it and you're like holy
[ __ ]
my mouth is right next to this [ __ ]
thing then it touches your lip you know
i mean you're just like oh god i was at
levity live in oxnard and i had to tell
the guy afterwards i was like yo dude
like you need to clean the mic
like that's been in someone's butt hole
it's so disgusting you know what i mean
so but so i always felt like we have
like you know i don't get sick a lot you
know i felt like but this is one of
these things where you go you know you
don't want to be like well comics aren't
going to get it but it's like damn it's
touching everybody you know what i mean
like
i was like
i i was worried about myself i'm worried
about people like bobby lee you know
what i mean like bobby's like a fat
little [ __ ] you know what i mean he's
like you know what i mean i'm worried
about myself i was well i burnt i saw
joe rogan talking about bert he was like
man i'm worried about you you know you
drink too much you're just in that
whatever so you know so i just feel like
i just bobby seems like he could be the
origin of the cro
yeah facial i just mean
[Laughter]
that he looks like he could be
someone that starts a lot of diseases
you know yeah you like ground zero two
shows i can't stand
shows any reality show where they're
just sitting there screaming and yelling
at each other and yeah
um
i remember even that orange county
motorcycles after a while i got sick of
listening to and argue i was like i just
build the [ __ ] bike i just want to
see you build the bike i don't need the
family drama i feel like i was dropping
in on that thanksgiving every episode
but um
the uh and that and then those those
stupid cooking shows where you don't
learn how to cook
that the competition ones it's just them
like yeah yeah i get and they and it's
just like yeah here's a styrofoam cup
and some sardines make lasagna you got
three minutes you're like huh i don't
know what to do and then they give it to
the guys and guys like yeah the sardines
were overpowering it's like yeah because
i had styrofoam with it
what am i supposed to do and then it
just
dude and then they do it with kids and
the [ __ ] kids are crying sometimes
i'm like
like what am i getting out of watching
this i'm just watching people getting in
trouble separation we need a little bit
of space so she can have her time and
then also just so she's not hearing me
recording voice over random stuff in the
other room like i would have to tell her
when i had a voiceover audition come up
can you be quiet
like 20 to 30 minutes that's a lot to
ask a person to not
when they're when they're home that's a
lot so rachel comes and she like closes
my door with an attitude you know
because yeah cause i'm in here like you
know
get your loadout on me on me you know
what i mean like how am i playing call
of duty she's like i wish you'd get his
load out on me i mean seriously i've
been here the whole time like what's
going on it's funny that she actually
had a response like that because she was
like what are you talking about in there
you're talking about your load again
so she just comes she closes the door
with a little bit of an attitude right
it's not a slam but that last two inches
yeah it's like shut the [ __ ] up
i was just talking about the just the
very
idea of the 15-minute break is so
[ __ ] insulting
really how so because what the [ __ ] am i
gonna do in 15 minutes yeah
what am i suppose what amount of
relaxation
am i supposed to get done in fifth 15
minutes it'll probably take you 17
minutes just to wind your brain down and
get away from all the nonsense that you
were just dealing with all day i know
exactly how it went when i had the job i
remember working at the grocery store
it's been the first five minutes talking
[ __ ] about whatever customer that pissed
me off before i spent that next five
picking out lunch for later or trying to
text someone at home making sure the
home life was okay and you spend that
last five looking at that clock wishing
you had that other minutes back yeah
it's not relaxing at all and just the um
i think a lot of people i've been
talking to on twitch people who have
been working from home who are now going
back to work is this that they're having
a hard time now i think like it's this
kind of thing like where you removed the
veil for a while and now you're trying
to put it back on yeah and people are
like no i can get the same amount of
work done in three hours as i used to do
coming here for eight hours a day yeah
and i don't have to deal with you
you know what i mean that that middle
management piece of [ __ ] that like that
person who thinks gumming up the worst
yeah yeah yeah they have to like you
know be like they make themselves feel
important so they're going to be all on
you it's like nah i know i can one i
don't got to get dressed you know so so
i could do this from home in a robe oh
you don't know how much i was cursing
you driving over here
yeah i know it's just you know
it is a better atmosphere and energy
once i got here for sure
[Music]
that was a trip man yeah you were a fan
favorite on tyso i mean yeah dude it's
just a uh but like you know your pod his
pod there's a there's a handful of them
that are real uh
real goofy and i like that yeah i mean
it is what it is man you know it's like
we're still doing this thing i think i
think by the way
you're just saying it is what it like
there's a certain amount of phrases that
i think people say like use reminded me
it just felt like we ran into each other
30 years from now at like outside of
like a subway or a tcby and like we
didn't really know how to catch up and
have been too much time
how come we haven't called each other
god adam it is what it is yeah life's
crazy man yeah
well the world man it's just yeah it's
just uh what a year what do you i mean
there's so many just staple statements
you can well that's like but that's
right now i mean you know you know you
think i always feel like like is the
world back to normal no i
i feel like
i feel like we're having an illegal
party at our friend's house and our
parent waiting for somebody's parent to
come home you know what i mean what a
great way to put it you know so we're
trying to have a good time but we're
just waiting we're hurrying up we're
waiting for kovan to bust in and be like
why are you standing next to each other
you old enough to be drinking that yeah
why don't you get a mask on you know
it's like it's like oh kovan's here
let's get out of here get out of my coat
get out of colvin's room you know so
it's like i feel like that's where we're
at right now so like i'm doing a lot of
shows i'm going out of town i'm doing it
i'm like trying to just milk it huh
trying to get it in while i can before
some you know the spirit airlines the
freaking
variant comes out and then what are we
gonna do can you imagine if like [ __ ]
really takes a turn and spirit somehow
like thrusts its way to the top of the
food chain where they're just like hey
we still don't serve water but
um the spirit airlines dude
what's their slogan one time i flew and
because you know why you fly spirit
because it says
120 to go to england you know what i
mean
with 42 stops you know you know and
you're like you're like oh [ __ ] this is
great yeah and then you're checking in
this is when they get you okay well do
you want to sit in a chair
did you bring your own chair yeah
because that's 250 dollars to sit in a
chair oh you got bags okay well that's a
bag fee
carry-on bag fee
you know you know whatever you like
where do you want to sit in the plane is
that you know they then it's like this
was eight thousand dollars all of a
sudden
yeah they don't really how did you do
this to me they're a little ass back
which what is their slogan though
because like southwest is want to get
away i think delta is um i know what it
is
fly the front spirit airlines is yeah it
is what it is
it's called a callback folks
marshall rug
this wasn't a huge deal to me this
wasn't uh i can't i understand how that
could happen yeah i listen i wouldn't
have done it oh but i understand what
could happen what i'm what what what got
heated wasn't the fact that you assumed
i watch it i'm just like man in fact my
ugh my ugg didn't even have an
exclamation point oh it was full caps
let's go back and look go ahead let's go
back and look i'll stay right here not
looking i'll just look at your face you
tell me if there's caps okay
yeah all right the first but it was
capital a capital u yeah cause there was
a period before it well then you should
know that you shouldn't put a period and
then do the uh no i'm still watching
period uh
that you're out of your mind
cause that's a rick voice text what got
me what got me heated i actually said i
actually said uh i actually said i'm
still watching period ugh period
what got me heated wasn't that you
spoiled it which you did which happens
i wanted to tell you that to condition
us so you know hey man next time
just say did you finish it what got me
upstairs oh oh and i'm saying to you hey
man next time open with oh i'm still
watching oh oh i learned my lesson oh
you're good did you learn to be upset
with something that you do all the time
oh here we go which is this
hey man you [ __ ] [ __ ] you should i'm
like eric what you spoiled what is that
where's that no the energy oh how do you
know the energy because i'm saying it's
something that you do all the time this
is who you are i'm not even talking
about american idol what about this is
who you are okay
it was you dude
and you are mister
i can't say that
i farted
on the honeymoon
and it was
probably
top five all time
you ever have a fart like that where
you're like
oh this is
wow
it was it was a wow
it was like resonant
d it came it was windy you know what i
mean it was just a deep
like
like i felt like oh
my body needed this it just was like
you know what i mean like it was
it was just one of those ones where like
you know we fart all the time i mean
everybody does but you know it's rare
that you have one where you go oh man
because it was it was it was memorable
because i was sitting on the beach you
know laying on this towel under this
thing and the wind was blowing and i
just was like oh i feel this and then it
just was like
rachel wasn't even around she was out
swimming so don't worry it wasn't like
it was in front of her i it was alone i
was alone but it was just one of those
ones where i was like what hello
hello i think like ships heard it and
we're gonna start coming to shore like
that's how powerful it was
just windy and and resonant
here's my thing
when we talking about pets there's only
two pets like i just said
a dog
and a cat
everything else is nonsense
nonsense people that got snakes
get out of my face
if you got a little trilantula aquarium
get out of my face
lizards iguanas uh you know people that
got like rats and hamsters and all this
kind of stuff get out of here that's not
a pet
a pet is something that you can let roam
free
and then you know you don't got to worry
about it or it's going to come to you
when you call it it's going to show you
some love if they don't show you love
it's not a pet the big one is people
that got fish tanks
fish tanks a fish is not a pet a fish
tank is basically a rock bath that's
what it is it's an expensive ass rock
bath i know a friend of mine a couple
they always fussing with a fish tank
always like oh man we just got this new
coral it's like 800
what so you bought a 800 rock that you
keep it in a bathtub
[Music]